[Музика]
Такая Медіна персона так штовхай Осама
розмах Остерія штовхай ми медове морозиво
над грудьми ой стихія Ахіл рок
сам великий клас ім'я бонус
запит сире м'ясо тим більше знати, чия
прірва емоційна, як Готем, коли
блокнот Чатема на телеком CdTe
відкритий над бізнесом
привіт мене звати Ольга манма я
вчитель англійської
це мої учні сьогодні ласкаво
просимо Григорій О ласкаво просимо Алена ласкаво просимо
дякую я маю на увазі як справи сьогодні я
добре дякую
дуже гарний настрій я схвильований гарний
Грегорі, що з тобою, я добре,
я люблю англійську, так, кнопка розмовляю
трохи, але я добре вчуся дуже добре,
добре,
і ти хочеш запитати мене так,
звичайно,
як справи, Ольга, сьогодні я
ідеальний,
дякую правильно давайте  почніть ти любиш
ігри так так добре,
ми пограємо в гру номер один я дам
вам підказку, ви побачите її на
екрані, і ви повинні вгадати тему,
про яку ми сьогодні будемо говорити,
ви готові добре так чудово
я  я маю поділитися з вами дуже особистою
інформацією минулої ночі
моя найкраща подруга Андреа, вона канадка, вона
надіслала мені приємне SMS, і я хотів би,
щоб ви прочитали це
хороший тест номер один, коли ви прочитаєте
SMS, спробуйте вгадати, про що буде
говорити сьогодні бабуся  добре, і про яку
тему сьогодні говорили правильно давайте
граматику і тему правильно добре Алена
може попросити вас прочитати, будь ласка,
так, звичайно, привіт, Ольга, вибачте, що
я з вами деякий час не спілкувався,
нещодавно був дуже зайнятий  Ми з моїм хлопцем
, і я щойно повернувся додому
з нашої поїздки до Нью-Йорка, і вгадайте, що
ви знаєте, я цікавився сучасним
мистецтвом ще зі студентських років, і нарешті
моя мрія відвідати MoMA ммм
здійснилася, чи можемо ми зупинити те, що  є мама-музей
музика,
чи вона створена в більш ніж більш ніж
ах дуже добре правильно я бачила всі
найбільші шедеври мистецтва 20-го
століття Фріда Кало
Мілева CH Пікассо і Далі, боже мій, і
я заплатив лише 25 доларів за це
у вас  бачив їхню мережу  сайт це дивовижно,
я дуже люблю їхній магазин, ми
провели там близько двох годин, і тепер у мене
є два творчих проекта дітей: унікальний
ти, дизайнерський годинник і милий блокнот,
сподіваюся, що ти сподіваюся, що ти скоро отримаєш, Андреа,
дуже дякую, все добре, вона
щаслива риба, це правильно питання для
Грегорі о так добре як звати мого друга
це мене звати як звати мого друга
Андреа Андреа дуже добре добре
Алена де вона була нещодавно - мама
вона була в гостях вона була в гостях у
мами місце це музей сучасності
Мистецтво яку країну беруть
Нью-Йорк дуже добре Грегорі з ким
вона поїхала з хлопцем
дуже добре добре Айлін це питання
, скільки вона заплатила за квиток
і дала мені лише п'ять баксів так
чудово дуже добре я хотів би
зверніть вашу увагу на одне слово у нас є
слово унікальний унікальний унікальний унікальний
давайте скажемо разом унікальний унікальний так
надзвичайно унікальний дуже добре, але щоб
пам'ятати, питання полягає в тому, що ви повинні були
вгадати  ss коли ти прочитаєш текст так
про час, коли ми будемо говорити так бабуся,
що бабуся так
подарує відмінно
чи знаєш ти Григорій будь-які випадки теперішнього часу
ідеальний у цьому тексті чи можеш ти прочитати
перший я був ще так я не був
дуже  добре, добре, що щодо цього
речення про найбільші твори монстра, чи
можете ви прочитати його, будь ласка, Олена, я
бачив усі найкращі шедеври,
дуже добре, так що граматика ви
здогадалися, що це ідеально, а
що щодо теми, я думаю, що це сучасне
мистецтво  так, це наш загалом дуже
добре все добре
дуже добре тепер у вас є бивні і
вся аудиторія, у вас є завдання, будь ласка,
прочитайте це самі зараз дуже уважно і
запишіть кількість випадків, присутніх
ідеально тут використовується, наприклад, вибачте, я
я з вами не зв'язувався, це
номер один, уважно прочитайте текст ще раз
і вирішіть, скільки разів
тут використано Present Perfect, просто скажіть мені,
скільки випадків ви можете працювати
разом,
щоб я думаю, що ми  мені потрібен номер, я думаю, що у нас
є число, ми просто порахуємо його, і я
сподіваюся, що ви маєте рацію, це п'ять разів або шість,
добре,
не дивлюся, це не означає, що я знову був дуже
зайнятий
, це знову чудово, один два три
[Музика]
п'ять шість, а потім вниз я просто бачу
список в останньому абзаці мм-хм правильно
мені потрібно остаточне число Сподіваюся, ви
прокоментували, що про вас, тому я думаю, що це
сім разів сім
Григорій, ваша пропозиція вісім вісім дуже
добре, давайте перевіримо всіх добре правильно
давайте порахуємо разом, вибачте, я не
був так номер один номер два Грегорі чи
можете ви прочитати номер два
я був так дуже зайнятий Алі ні номер
три я щойно отримав дуже
дякую Грегорі мм-хм
мені було цікаво це цікавить
в мене цікавить дуже добре
те, що цікавить те, що тебе
цікавить Грегорі о, мене
цікавить я впевнений, я можу здогадатися, я маю на увазі, ти
цікавишся музикою, яка мене цікавить
, щоб бути дуже  добре, добре, так
що не було раніше чужорідного і прекрасного h  як
збулося, збулося, я бачив дуже
гарне число шість, слабкість зникне так,
номер сім
, ви бачили дуже гарні вісім і дев'ять
[Музика],
яку ви пропустили, яку ви не
помітили, настільки вражений,
ймовірно, здійснився  справді
дуже добре так, чи можу я повернутися до
чогось, про що згадував Грегорі, мене
цікавить, тож у нас є, будь ласка, зверніть
увагу, що у нас є словниковий запас
або бабуся, що-небудь, що мутант придумає
під час уроку, ми будемо виправляти це
тут, о, відразу Грегорі  чи можете ви сказати
це слово, будь ласка, унікальний відмінний дуже
унікальний та синонім Олена Я
згадував синонім раніше професійний
професіонал
у надзвичайно дуже добре добре
добре цікавитися бути
зацікавленим у хорошому бути зацікавленим
таким чином, щоб дійсно подобатися щось так, ви
знаєте, щоб  мати пристрасть до
чогось дуже хорошого тому я Ніна
цікавлюся хорошим цікавлюся я
цікавлюся музикою я цікавлюся
мистецтвом що ще нас може
цікавити і само-а  обізнаність так, якщо
ви цікавитеся війною, хороші
люди можуть цікавитися спортом так
дуже добре
більше, ніж література, будь-що
добре, щоб цікавитися, але в нашому випадку
ми маємо це, мене цікавить
мене цікавить  ідеальна
форма так, я цікавився більш
ніж дивними братами і сестрами хорошими коледжами з часів мого
навчання в коледжі, коли я навчався в коледжі, я
цікавився мистецтвом, я
цікавився ним усе своє життя, і я все
ще цікавлюся, це довгий процес
так, ось чому ми використовуємо цей гарний дуже
гарний подарунок досконалий ми подивимося
на це більше дуже добре чи готові
ми продовжити так
тепер досконалий дякую за
визначення цього часу більшість
студентів намагаються
відрізнити минуле просте так і теперішнє
ідеально мм-хм, але давайте подивимось, Грегорі, чи
можу я попросити вас прочитати перше речення,
будь ласка, прочитайте так, так, я люблю цих буча
востаннє, так мм-хм, і я, Ніна номер два,
будь ласка, я вже прочитав цю книгу так,
яка різниця
зверніть увагу на підкреслені слова
дуже добре, коли я говорю минулого року я маю на увазі, що
це важливо, коли я читаю це коли
я говорю про коли так і коли я
кажу, що я вже говорю про
результат так я знаю, що це за книга  це
приблизно
ммм-хм, дуже добре, так, коли ви
згадуєте точний час, ми використовували б
, як називаються ці терміни
past simple, а цей, який ми
виявляємо сьогодні, є відмінним
вергісом, тож основна відмінність в
українській мові ми насправді маємо те
саме  ми просто ніколи не помічали, що це
конан закінчено, підходьте до іриски"
Tov
так, я пам'ятаю, якщо марсіани
обідають так, нульовий хоробрий марсіанин - це
я Таня, мм-хм, це
ідеально, так, купе для полегшення, якщо
ви можете сказати так, Cooper Walla, ви  're
cupola result mm-hmm, коли ви кажете тут
Cooper valid say Oba booster raineesha
ви мали на увазі, ніби це було важливо, де що-
небудь інше alia компілятор результати
Я маю це зараз, так, це
головна відмінність це слова, які
завжди  допоможіть нам визначити справжній
ідеальний ніколи я ніколи не був в
Австралії я ніколи не був в Австралії
мм-хм Мексика я ніколи не був у Мексиці
ніколи ми використовуємо це для запитань чи
ви коли-небудь читали прочитати цю книгу ще
раз прочитати  читай друже ти коли-небудь читав
цю книгу чудово ми повернемося до
нормального тіла дуже добре добре
ти коли-небудь читав цю книгу, але ми
сказали, що ще щось не зробили правильно я
ще не купив цю книгу я ще не купив цю книгу
я ще зробив свою домашню роботу з років коледжу
ще не перелив певну музику хто був
напружений Мене це цікавило так, вибачте,
ви бачите, це іди так, так як це
буде правильно так тепер ідеальний ще, щоб
обробити якусь музику, о, ти, десять речей, які
я"  я цікавився так і музикою тоді
так з років коледжу
це дуже добре я цікавлюся з
тих пір так дуже добре дуже добре
добре
о, я дуже давно цікавлюся музикою
я не бачив свого найкращого
друга  дуже давно добре, тому що
ми зараз не повинні зустрічатися  один
одному просто показують їм добре я
щойно випив каву я щойно отримав її
повідомлення у мене є тільки Бог, і це вже
є улюбленим для всіх, вже добре
так, як би ви сказали, Грегорі так,
підійди до своєї тактики зараз, де твій
Боб замовк уже прочитаний  читати читати так
о, це дуже складно так, я знаю, що
це божевільно, тому що читати читати читати
орфографія абсолютно однакова так так,
ви просто повинні пам'ятати читати читати читати
я читав дуже добре так так так дуже
добре і давайте подивимося на  кілька
випадків насправді мої студенти сьогодні
дуже добре використовують Present Perfect просто
для перегляду так, тому ми повинні використовувати
parvo has і третю форму, яка настільки
проста, як я бачив, я зробив я був
я виграв ммм дуже добре він  ніколи не
був надто гарним так, він ніколи не малював
картини мм-хм добре, вони щойно
купили нову картину, як вони щойно
купили нову картину, дуже легко
запам'ятати про наймання has або has
плюс дієслово
в його третьому телефоні так дуже goo  d однак
має плюс yeah дієслово do you slow yes
або третій фільм IDI якщо він
правильний так, якщо це звичайний телефон
працював мм-хм, і ви називаєте їх
досить доступними бідністю мм-хм я
ніколи не працював на заводі
дуже добре  і Грегорі, чи не могли б ви
нагадати нам, коли ми використовуємо пройшло, для
кого ми використовуємо це я скажу, що ми використовуємо have
і чи вона так дякую дуже
дякую дуже гарно і ще одне
цікаве узагальнення старої
інформації добре завжди пам'ятати в  ваша
голова я читав цю книгу минулого року і я
прочитав ви читали цю книгу
це основний результат випадка, але ми використовуємо present
perfect не тільки для того, щоб говорити про результат ми
говоримо про життєвий досвід я ніколи не
мав у вас життєвого досвіду скільки часу
це про музику Олени так як
давно ти цікавишся музикою
про результат наша книжкова історія Russia Tov
незавершені дії це дуже особливе,
якщо щось відбувається протягом цього
року цього тижня сьогодні ми використовуємо present
perfect котрий Emerson amo ju  st дитина
не дуже показується, оскільки він прийшов до приспіву,
наприклад, я сьогодні не пив кави,
тому що сьогодні мм-хм
добре так, о, я не бачила його цього року,
добре, просто дуже хороший учень, сподіваюся, що
всі є  записую так, як
робить Аліна, просто тому, що я постійно роблю ці помилки,
тому що я не пам'ятаю,
що нам потрібно використовувати це в життєвому
досвіді, скільки часу результат і
все, тому я записую це останні
дії пишу те, що сталося з
нами нещодавно це  добре, правда, нещодавно
як би ви сказали Грегоріні псевдонім
Родіно ви
моя справа нещодавно правильно для вас
нещодавно моя сім'я і я
моя сім'я і я як нещодавно я і моя сім'я
були мм-хм добре
добре, я можу повторити нещодавно моїй родині
сподобалося так, моє  сім'я і все добре, і
я і я нещодавно ми з сім'єю
ходили на ринок або в
магазин
я думаю, що ринки дуже гарні, добре,
це дуже цікавий момент, Грегорі
англійською, хоча ми говоримо так
через Родена в ЗМІ  о ти англійською це
мої друзі і я моя сім'я і велосипед
Майкл і я о мій так добре вони
сказали б, і я ніколи не посадили мене або я спочатку
так
дуже добре дозвольте мені звільнити місце
Ейлін я збираюся позбутися цього  слово
на дошці Сподіваюся, ви запам'ятаєте його зараз,
вам потрібно так добре, так насправді багато
людей мають проблему, яка виникла у вас із
запам'ятовуванням цих неправильних дієслів, які
регулярні woops ви пам'ятаєте неправильні
whoops go go gone read read так,
зробили відмінно
вони нудні для  навчитися grande так,
давайте подивимося на деякі з них дуже
гарні, добре
Грегорі, чи можу я попросити вас прочитати нам
кілька лінійних суддів, які не пішли
, ви зробили, зробили це взяли взяти
shake shake shake shaken кампанії прийшли виграти один
один став став стати  початок
почався добре, хлопці, вам весело, коли
ви вивчаєте ці неправильні слова, якщо
нелегко запам'ятати їх усі я не
знаю
так
, розважаючись зі звичайними черв'яками, ви
думаєте, що це дуже приємно цікаво,
захоплююче, ви не виглядаєте як  якщо ти  ти
схвильований дуже добре, у
нас є Аліна, яка дуже творча
людина і допомагає нам добре Аліна я думаю, що я
можу це зробити так, так, як ми можемо зробити це
весело Адіна, я не знаю однієї речі, яку я
добре пам'ятаю зі свого дитинства
завжди добре спробувати щось заспівати, щоб
зрозуміти і запам'ятати так добре, молодець,
зараз ми перевіримо, чи допомогло це
Григорію запам'ятати їх чудово
Айлін, тобі потрібна інша
справа, боже мій, чувак, потрібно отримати
дохід від коктейлів, ми хочемо, щоб ти
став королем, щоб зробити це добре, і
найцікавіше, що ти можеш зробити
це самостійно, подивись на список, який ти
знаєш, коли дивишся на  цей список
звичайних слів вони жахливі, вони
нудні,
зробіть це зараз так, так, ви можете класифікувати
їх, як вам подобається, і зробити так, щоб це працювало
так добре, дякую,
але ви можете самі добре змішати, тому це
буде пісня в понеділок, а потім  ви можете
зробити те, що на вівторок  y та середа
дуже добре не забудьте перевірити себе
на правопис добре так правильно так, давайте пограємо в
іншу гру,
і знову ця гра підходить не тільки
для теперішньої ідеальної редакції, або для будь-якої
іншої версії граматики, ви можете грати в неї
зі своїми друзями.  подивіться зараз
правильно, добре, Грегорі, у вас є картки
із запитаннями, які вам потрібно прочитати
своєму однокласнику так, я
тут чудовисько у відповіді, ми хотіли б, щоб
ви використали present perfect добре, я
ніколи не був на гарячій кулі в  моє життя
мм-хм, то можу я запитати тебе щось так
, ти коли-небудь брав участь у шкільній
виставі, і це круто добре грати шкільна вистава
сцена на чотири заїзди Різдвяна вистава так
шкільна вистава
давайте подзвонимо, ви коли-небудь брали участь
у  участь у так, я маю взяти участь, щоб
взяти його так, я взяв участь добре так,
Gregor тут я пропоную інфінітив, а
потім дякую так, дуже добре,
так, дуже добре, ви коли-
небудь змагалися чиясь робота в школі
так килим килим звуки  Я добре працюю в
школі, це правда
добре, так що, на жаль, правда в тому, що
я дійсно зробив у своєму житті в
шкільні часи, коли я була хитрою
дівчиною, але тепер я намагаюся стати краще, у мене
є питання до вас, добре, ви
коли-небудь читав цілу книгу за один день і
насолоджуйся книгою від початку до
кінця
так цілий сьогодні ні ні взагалі у
твоєму житті я читав я можу
читати цілий час так, я
охоплюю цілу книгу в одній  введіть твій
один день так, це моє життя одного дня так, так,
так, я можу прочитати всю книгу цілу
книгу ага, я міг би ще раз я
прочитав цілу книгу минулого року Вау, так, минулого
року, о, чи можемо ми використовувати минулий рік, коли ми говоримо
про сьогодення  ідеально минулого року, хм, чи можемо
ми змінити це речення, будь ласка, я
читав я читав ні я Керол Енн так
вся вся книга так,
книга так, я прочитав цілу, якщо ми
хочемо сказати минулого року так я читав так я
читав так я читав так  Я читав щойно зробив це минулого
року добре, так, повністю світло може бути
цілком да  y так, все так добре слово
добре, ви коли-небудь бачили один і той самий фільм
п'ять разів
о так, я бачив один фільм, мабуть, п'ять
разів, напевно
, це П'ятий елемент щороку
перед новим роком його показують, тому я
дивлюся з великим задоволенням,
це  гарний фільм дякую, дякую,
у нас є ще запитання
Ні так дуже добре
мої учні Я бачу, що ви готові
до іспиту так добре, зараз стає
серйозним
так дуже добре, у нас є вирок, і ви
повинні вирішити, чи можете ви піти  for
past simple або present perfect here hey
right, зроби це самостійно, і ми перевіримо
це лише три речення давайте почнемо
Олена, чи можете ви прокоментувати перше
речення, добре, щоб Вінчі намалював
Таємну вечерю в 15 столітті, дякую
і чому ми  використовуйте past simple тут,
тому що ми маємо точний час, коли ви
так, це відбувається Дякую, Григорій
номер два, заборона Бенксі став популярним
зовсім недавно, це було ваше
слово нещодавно нещодавно нещодавно національне
нещодавно стало так, так ве  Остання
подія стала популярною зовсім нещодавно дуже
гарна нещодавня подія і Аліна брекеті нова
гравітація
[Музика]
з'явилася мм-хм
будівля музею минулої ночі, тому
що минулої ночі минулої ночі саме тоді, коли
так, гарно молодці мої студенти,
молодці, я закликаю всіх використовувати
презентувати ідеальний у вашій розмові, тому що
насправді навіть українською мовою ми робимо
багато nakorn, розуміємо, чи не так,
Ruby a via Cooper V вдячний за
cheerio, ви повинні робити більше Webster
, це різниця,
коли ви смієтеся, чим більше Webster, коли ви  скажи, що мама
сміється, так, це ти знаєш, означає, що у тебе
немає дослідника, коли ти кажеш, що
тим більше Вебстер відчуває полегшення від
поклоніння, яке виконується так ідеально
дякую, мої учні за
ідеальний урок так, добре, добре, ви
можете  завжди дивіться урок знову і
знову на одному з каналів і переглядайте
всю інформацію, дякую,
дякую всім,
дякую,
о, чоловік, рік, вамос, додатковий платник
на моджаві  e booty ricotta Melanie
ваша рогова міс Larock тільки scholastic
пограбування відключить це не преміум
видання так Joe ні, якщо турецький
поні dilka torch ні Бред марокканський гелі-
лижний черевик у сутінках аналогічно Шаманов
extra chuyia Моніка
випадок єгипетська алеена по нашій далеко  гладка ненавиділа
своїх коней проблема добре я знаю, що
ракета зазвичай трохи зайнята давайте попливемо, як
Мохаммед сказав прийти
[Музика]
ти